[موسيقى]
وقف فقير جائع على باب ثري بخيل يطلب
احسانا فقال له الشحيح اذهب من هنا النساء
لسنا في المنزل فرد السائل المسكين انني
اسالك رغيفا اكله وليس عروسا اتزوجها يقول
الامام علي رضي الله عنه يعيش البخيل في
الدنيا عيش الفقراء ويحاسب في الاخره حساب
الاغنياء الى العناوين
عبس اردوغان وضحك الاسد فوق ركام الزلزال
تجار الزلازل ولصوص المساعدات في اوج
الموسم
حاخام اسرائيلي بارز زلزال تركيا وسوريا
انتقام الهي
برشلونه تقاطع اسرائيل والرئيس اركان جيش
الاحتلال في البحرين
السيسي يضع حدا للتراصق بين اعلاميين
مصريين وخليجيين
ماكرون يسيء للجزائر والمغرب وتونس وروسيا
ويعانقوا
الغنوشي للثوره الاسلاميه الايرانيه دور
كبير في الصحبه الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا عبس اردوغان متنقلا بين الطائره
والسياره وغرف الاجتماعات يواكب الرئيس
التركي حصاد الزلزال الكارثي الذي لا يبعد
كثيرا عن موعد الانتخابات اثناء مقابلته
المنكوبين كان دائما التجهم في الوجه لكنه
يؤكد ويشدد على ان الدوله كما وقفت سابقا
ستقف اليوم مع شعبها في برامج الاغاثه
والاعمار
[موسيقى]
سميع الد
عاء
لماذا كل هذا العبوس والتجهم على وجه
اردوغان شو صاير زلزال ليش وحدك صار عندك
زلزال ابي رجب تفضل صور سيلفي ضحك عفوي
عناق واستياق ابتسامات وزغاريد
ولادي وقدي وحبي ضحكي
ولادي وحب ضحكي ولعبه جد وحب
ضحكه ولادي وجدي وحب على الضحكه وعلى ما
اسمعي المكلومين يعلن بشار بعد 120 ساعه
بان المناطق التي زلزلت ارضها منكوبه
مشغولا بتلقي الاتصالات وعودتها مؤيد محور
الممانعه دافعوا عن انتقاد ضحكات الاسد
وابتساماته في مقابل ملامح الحزن التي لم
تفارق وجهها اردوغان بمعطيين متناقضين
اولا ان كل هذه الفيديوهات والصور
للابتسامه والضحك مفبركه المعطى الثاني
يقول ولماذا لا يبتسم بشار عبوسوا اردوغان
تمثيل يقولون عنده انتخابات اما نحن
فانتخبنا الاسد
ومع ذلك حلب منوره منوره بسياده الرئيس
وليست منكوبه شو بده يعملكم الشعب هيك
مرتاحة
اليوم بزيارتكم حلب ماله
منوره الله يطول بعم جوله الرئيس السوري
في حلب كانت مناسبه لشكرك قائد الحشد
الشعبي العراقي الملقب بابي فدك على دوري
قواته في معارك حلب
زلزال مرمره في تركيا نهايه الالفيه
الماضيه صعب شروط البناء في البلاد بحيث
اضيفت عليها خاصيه مقاومه الزلازل زلزال
كهرمان مراش او قهرمان مرعش كشف ان الكثير
من الشروط الهندسيه لا تتجاوز حبرا على
ورق في تنفيذ البناء السلطات التركيه القت
القبض على مقاوضين انشئوا بنايات حديثه
انهارت بالكامل وقد تمكنت الشرطه من
اللحاق بعدد منهم بينما كانوا يهمون
بالهرب والتواري عن الانظار داخل البلاد
او خارجها وذكرت المعلومات ان عمليات
التوقيف قد تتوسع لتشمل المزيد من
المتعهدين خصوصا ان تركيا تعتمد قوانين
بناء صارمه هدفها منعو مثل تلك الكارثه
حملات قال طالت ايضا لصوصا استغلوا
الزلزال بغياب الناس عن متاجرها وبيوتها
ليسرقوها في وضح النهار الرئيس اردوغان
توعد هؤلاء اللصوص الذين لا يشبهون الامه
التركيه بحسب تعبيره
هل مررنا قانون حاله الطوارئ لقد مررناه
لماذا مررناه حتى لا يستغل اللصوص الزلزال
كانت هناك بعض عمليات النهب في بعض
الاماكن وقد سرقت الاسواق فكروا في الامر
هذه الامه لا تلجا الى الخطا مطلقا لو
اتصلوا باصحاب تلك الاسواق لاعطوهم كل ما
لديهم في سوريا لم يعتقل تجار الزلازل
وناهبوا المساعدات الانسانيه لانهم بحسب
المعارضين هم الذين يعتقلون الاخرين وقد
اعتقلوا فعلا الناسط الموالي للنظام معين
علي بعد هذا الكلام
عن طريق مبدا المحافظه لازم نروح نوصل
المساعدات اللي عندنا يا اخي العالم بتوسخ
فيكم شو بعمل
منقول لا يا خيو نوع الامانه وبننزل لعند
اعطيكن
اياهن المساعدات الاغاثيه الدوليه توزع
ضمن مناطق سيطره النظام السوري فقط بحسب
المتحدث باسم الصليب الاحمر الدولي
الامانات بالحظ والصون لكن الاعلام
الاجنبي يشكك بمصير المساعدات فيما يتحدث
الاعلام المحلي عن سرقه موصوفه لها بينما
خذل المجتمع الدولي الشمال السوري المنكوب
تهافتت المساعدات في اول ايام الكارثه على
مناطق الاسد اشرفت على نقل المساعدات التي
وصلت مطاري دمشق وحلب وسرقت كميات كبيره
منها هلا انا ماشي بنص الشام بلاقي العالم
عم تبيع المعلبات
والزعتر والصابون وكلياته بالكراتين
المعونه وال ما وصلت لها الحلب ولا لاي
بلد لاي منطقه من مناطق سوريا اللي تضرروا
بيوصلوا دغري للشارع الثوره ولجسر الرئيس
لينباعوا بالطرقات الامم المتحده تقر
بتخليها عن الشمال السوري المعارض للاسد
لقد خذلناهم تقول بكل هدوء وتامل الا وكيل
الامن العام للامم المتحده ومنسق الاغاثه
في حالات الطوارئ مارتن جريفيث في تغريده
على موقع تويتر ان من كوبي الزلزال في
شمال سوريا على حق في شعورهم بالتخلي عنهم
وهم يتطلعون الى مساعده دوليه لم تصل ابدا
ما نفع الاعتذار والناس قضت تحت الركام ما
نفع الاعتذار والاطفال التيتمت على موائد
اللئام وما نفع الاعتذار من شعب قتل وضرب
وهجر قبل زلزله الارض ولم تهتز لنكبته
قائمه من كراسي الحكان
لحد الان في اكتر من 500 شهيد
في اكثر من 1300 تعليق تحت الارض قلنا لكم
نستعجلوا لحقونا
قلنا لكم اطفالنا تحت الركام بس تتنفس
افتحوا لنا المعبر
افتحونا معبر خلو اليات تدخل تطالع هالناس
من تحت وتاخرتو بعد كلكم
خلاص
ركام نحن بنشيل الركام بنطلع الشهداء خلص
انقطع النفس الى ديان يوم الدين نمضي وعند
الله تجتمع الخصوم
اداره الكوارث التركيه حددت الطاقه
المنبعثه من الزلزال بانها تعادل طاقه 500
قنبله ذريه
فماذا تعادل الصواريخ والبراميل التي قتل
بها السوريون بمئات الالاف من البشر
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد يقرر فك عزله
الرئيس السوري
والمثل البرازيلي يقول جيتنا يا مسعد
لتسعد طلع بدك مين يسعدك جدلك في بيان
لرئاسه التونسيه عقب لقاء جمع سعيد بوزير
الخارجيه الجديد نبيل عمار الذي خلف
الثلاثاء عثمان الجراندي موقف سعيد ياتي
منسجمًا مع موقف ابوظبي التي ارسلت
المساعدات واوفدت وزير خارجيتها الى الاسد
ونقل الوزير الضيفه تعازي صاحب الصمو
الشيخ محمد بن زايد ال نهيان رئيس دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده وصاحب سمو الشيخ
محمد بن راشد ال مكتوم رئيس مجلس الوزراء
حاكم دبي الى الرئيس الاسد والشعب السوري
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني
كان اول الزعماء الذين وصلوا الى اسطنبول
حيث اجتمع مع الرئيس اردوغان معزيا بضحايا
الزلزال وقد جرى بحث التطورات في المنطقه
اضافه الى العلاقات الاستراتيجيه القائمه
بين البلدين مؤكدا مساهمه الدوحه في
التخفيف من كارثه تركيا وذلك بعد ان تبرع
لضحايا الزلزال في شمال سوريا وفي تركيا
مفتتحا حمله عون وسند القطريه في الشمال
السوري
كبير حاخامات صفد في دوله الاحتلال
شاموئيل الياهو قال ان الزلزال انتقام
الهي من الاتراك والسوريين كما انتقم الله
من فرعون باغلاقه في البحر مضيفا ان هذا
عقاب الرب لمن اراد سوءا
بالاسرائيليين رصدت قناه الجديد تغريده
لاحد
اللبنانيين يقول فيها يا اردوغان رجع
كنيسه ايه صوفيا مثل ما كانت في التاريخ
وحافظ على نظافه هذا الوطن من كل النواحي
ثم ترحم على الابرياء وقد تعرض الممثل
لانتقادات واسعه من قبل المتابعين
المسيحيين تحديدا الذين اعتبروا ان كلامه
يناقض الفهم المسيحي والاهبل منهم كلهم هو
اللي طلع يقنعنا انه الله ضرب تركيا ردا
على اللي عملوا اردوغان باي صوفيا انا بعد
ما شفت احقر وانزل من هيك تفكير صراحه
اكثر من خمسين لبنانيا من المسيحيين
والمسلمين توزعوا بين قتيل ومفقود في هذا
الزلزال
عباره تختزل كل امال اصدقاء ليصلح الحداد
في انقذه والا تكون رحلتهم الى تركيا بحثا
عن صديقهم ضاعت سدى ركض محمد لمحمد عثر
عليه في غرفته في الفندق حيث كان فيما لا
يزال البحث مستمرا عنه عن الياس الحداد
وعن عائله عجاج وغيرهم من اللبنانيين وان
عدد الضحايا اللبنانيين بلغ حتى الان 22
قتيلا فيما عدد المفقودين يتجاوز الثلاثين
حتما من يربط زلزله تركيا بتحويل كنيسه
ايه صوفيا الى مسجد هل يتوقع ربطا حدوث
زلازل مماثله في اسبانيا التي طمست معالم
معظم مساجدها التاريخيه وحولتها الى كنائس
حتى يومنا هذا وفي اليونان التي حولت 329
مسجدا واثرا اسلاميا في البلاد الى كنائس
وفي ارمينيا التي حولت مسجدا في
الى حظيره خنازير وغيرها الكثير والكثير
من المساجد التي حولها الغزو الاوروبي في
شمال افريقيا العربيه الى كنائس ومستودعات
اسلحه نسال الله تعالى ان يحمي كل هذه
البلاد من كل سوء النكبات تجمع ما فرقته
الخلافات واليونان الارثوذكسيه وقفت الى
جانب تركيا المسلمه فقدمت المساعدات
وقصوره المسافات حتى ان وزير الخارجيه
التركيه قال لنظيره اليوناني الزائر
سنطبعه علاقاتنا معكم فالجار الجيد يظهر
وقت الضيق
وللتعبير عن الاخوه الانسانيه لم يكن ابلغ
من النشيد الوطني التركي تذيعه كنيسه في
بلجيكا تضامنا مع ضحايا الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اعلنت رئيسه بلديه برشلونه اداه الله
تجميد كافه العلاقات المؤسسيه مع اسرائيل
بما في ذلك الغاء اتفاقيه التوام بين
المدينه وتل ابيب ردا على ارتكاب اسرائيل
جرائم الفصل العنصري الابرتهايد بحق
الفلسطينيين وانتهاكها المتكرر لحقوق
الشعب الفلسطينيه في الوقت الذي كانت فيه
مدينه برشلونه الاسبانيه تقطع علاقاتها مع
المؤسسات الاسرائيليه كانت حكومه البحرين
تحاول تهريب زياره رئيس اركان جيش
الاحتلال هرتز للمنامه مشاركا في مؤتمر
عسكري دولي لكن صوره له نشرتها الصحف
البحرينيه دون انتباه منها فضحت الزياره
حيث كان ضمن زوار ولي العهد البحريني في
المنام
من طبع مع اسرائيل لتدعمه في امنه ماذا
سيفعل اذا انفجرت في دوله الاحتلال حرب
اهليه الكلام ليس حلما عربيا رومانسيا بل
هو اتهام صريح ومتبادل من اطراف الخلاف في
تل ابيب وتحذير عاجل من رئيس اسرائيل
قاسيه عليكم لكنها الحقيقه هي اخبار
اسرائيليه وليست تحليلات
نحن لسنا في سجال سياسي بل على حافه
انهيار قانوني وعلى عتبه انفجار مستوى
التوتر في الخطاب العام في اسرائيل وصل
الى حد الدعوه الى التمرد في الجيش والى
حد تبادل الاتهامات وطاقاتف المسؤوليات
بين الاقطاب السياسيه الاسرائيليه
المختلفه عن امكانيه الوصول الى حرب اهليه
وسفك دماء في ضوء ما يجري على الارض
وضع الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي حدا
لحمله التراشق بين اعلاميين مصريين
وخليجيين ما ننساش وقفه اشقائنا معنا
يعني معنى كده لما انا انا هقول بقى فرديه
مش موجوده يعني لو في
ازمه انا اطول لساني لا تنسوا الفضل بينكم
بعض المقالات اللي
اشوفها مع شقائنا في المملكه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انا بتكلم لا لا احنا
حارسين وده توجه دوله وارجو ان احنا كلنا
كمواطنين ننتبه ان احنا لا ننساق ورا
مواقع تقصد الفتنه بينا لو في تصريح
هنقوله كدوله بشكل رسمي فلو احنا ما قلناش
ده يبقى الامور كلها ماشيه طيبه المهم ان
الرئيس السيسي يؤكد ان الدوله والحكومه لا
تتدخلوا في وسائل الاعلام وبالتالي فان
وسائل الاعلام لا تمثل تعبيرا عن الموقف
الرسمي اقل حاجه نعملها ان احنا نسكت ما
كناش نقول كلام طيب فاحنا نسكت الكلام ده
بينطبق مش بس على كده حتى على وسائل
اعلامنا اللي احنا ما بنتدخلش فيها
هل مارست فرنسا هوايتها التاريخيه
الاحتلاليه التي يسمونها استعماريه بانشطه
المافيا في الجزائر عبر تهريبها الاسبوع
الماضي ناشطه جزائريه مطلوبه للقضاء امر
الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون باستدعايه سفير
الجزائر بفرنسا السيد سعيد موسى فورا
للتشاور نعرب عن احتجنا بشده على عمليه
الاجلاء السريه وغير القانونيه لاميره
بوراوي المطلوبه للقضاء الجزائري سجنت
اميره بوراوي التي تحمل الجنسيتين
الفرنسيه والجزائريه في العام 2020 بتهم
عديده ثم اطلق سراحها في الثاني من شهر
يوليو 2020 حيث تواجه حكما بالسجن لمده
عامين بتهمه الاساءه للدين الاسلامي
المدعوه اميره بوراوي هربت عبر تونس وباذن
خاص من الرئيس قيس سعيد بحسب الصحيفه
الفرنسيه
اوقفت الناشطه التي تحمل ايضا الجنسيه
الفرنسيه في تونس حيث كانت تواجه خطر
الترحيل الى الجزائر وافرج عنها بعد
حصولها على حمايه القنصريه الفرنسيه في
تونس بحسب صحيفه
فقد تم استقبال بوراوي لبضع ساعات في
السفاره الفرنسيه قبل الحصول على اذن من
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد بالذهاب الى
فرنسا هذا التهريب عبر تونس كاد ان يتسبب
لها بطبيعه ازمه مع الجزائر التي احتجزت
شرطتها الحدوديه 200 سياره مدنيه تونسيه
على الحدود بداعي التفتيش الدقيق لكن
الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون يتدخل في
الوقت المناسب فيكفي الجزائر خلافها مع
المغرب يرى محليلون امر الرئيس الجزائري
عبد المجيد تبون مساء الجمعه بعدم ازعاج
وعرقله المواطنين التونسيين الاشقاء في
مراكز العبور الراغبين في الدخول او
الخروج من والى الجزائر مشاكل فرنسا
المستجده ليست فقط مع الجزائر فالمغرب
ينهي مهام سفيره في باريس بالتزامن مع
تبني البرلمان الاوروبي توصيه تنتقد ما
يصفه بتدهور حريه الصحافه في المغرب بهيج
شخص غير مسؤول يقول منذ ان تبجح ايمانويل
ماكرون قبل سنتين بقوله الرخو البليد ان
الاسلام يعيش ازمه في كل مكان بالعالم منذ
ذلك الحين ومكرون يعيش ازمه في كل مكان
بالعالم وهي ازمه غريبه على الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه الحديثه ماكرون لا يستبعد سحب
وسام جوقه الشرف الفرنسي برتبه فارس
الصليب الاكبر من الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين يعلن ذلك بينما يمنح الرئيس
الاوكراني بولوديمير زيلينسكي وسام جوقه
الشرف وهناك مثل لقبائل الزولو يقول ليش
بتحط راسك مع هالروس اذا راسك مش قد الروس
[موسيقى]
يه
ان للثوره الايرانيه دورا كبيرا في الصحوه
الاسلاميه في العالم هذا الكلام لم يقله
ابو فدك بل رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
على هامش احتفال سفاره طهران في تونس
بالذكرى الرابعه والاربعين لانتصار الثوره
[موسيقى]
اخيرا غيرت الحكومه الهنديه عيد الحب سان
فالنتاين ليصبح يوم عناق البقر وقد علل
بيان حكومي القرار بان البقره هي المانحه
للجميع وهي توفر الثروات للبشريه اقول هذا
الخبر ليس للسخريه من الهندوس بل للاشاره
الى انهم لم يجدوا انفسهم مضطرين لمجرات
الغرب في ثقافته وطقوصه فربطوا كل اعيادهم
وطقوصهم بمعبودهم مع انه بقره
[موسيقى]
ختاما سالت الميدن استاذه عن معنى المثل
الشهير الطيور على اشكالها تقع فاجابه
بقول مالك ابدي دينار لا يتفق اثنان في
عشره ودوام صحبه الا وفي احدهما وصف من
الاخر
يتشابهان لكنه راى يوما غرابا مع حمامه
فتعجب للحظات قبل ان يمشياه فاذا هما
اعرجان
ختم الاستاذ للتلميذ كذلك البشر على
اشكالهم يقعون كما تقع الطيور على اشكالها
فلا يصادق الصقر غرابا وليالف الهدهد بومه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الصديق الزين الوفي نعمه من الله
يمشي معاك المخاطر دربك يندله على الحلوه
والمره يمك ما يوم تملا
والصقر يخاوي صقر ما يخاوي الغراب ما
يخاوي الغراب
[موسيقى]